Prashad on the milestone have embraced
its huge challenge and have a lot of
satisfied customers but both restaurants
had problems in their kitchens and front
of house now I have to decide who
deserves a place in the final
this has to be the toughest challenge
both restaurants have ever faced quite
frankly on both restaurants I was
disappointed because I knew that the
personalities didn't shine tonight you
undersold yourselves for sure I didn't
see Bobby the face of poshard tonight
let's be honest Master and I felt that
you spent far too long get those first
three or four tables in i'm standing
outside knocking get the orders in get
these guys out the traps
and on the back of your performance and
your performance let me tell you it is
so difficult to gauge an outright winner
two phenomenal restaurants were put on
the spot today the restaurant going
through to the final
is
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you thank you gotcha trailer any
good [ __ ] but end of the day we get us
best still proud of what we did really
proudly James the boys in the restaurant
Chino get something else yet yeah
welcome yes good job you're in the final
and good luck thank you
what a final prasad vs Casimir a small
20 seater vegetarian indian resham from
bradford up against young guns the
michigan star boys tip for the top
[ __ ] game on